450 m² de trouvailles à petit prix dans
cette ressourcerie on pourra trouver de
tout pour s'habiller équiper sa maison
l'association ressourcez-vous s'installe
à guyancourt la commune mettant les
locaux à disposition
elle a pour objectif de récupérer les
objets que les gens ne souhaitent plus
garder vous aussi les entreprises ou
encore les collectivités donc à la
récupération aussi auprès de partenaires
divers et variés et ensuite elle a pour
objectif de les réemployer de vous de le
réutiliser en tout cas où si elle ne
peut pas de les recycler vers les bonnes
filières de recyclage des ateliers de
sensibilisation et de réparation seront
aussi proposés cinq à huit salariés de
l'association et en insertion un service
civique et des bénévoles seront aussi
présents sur site les premiers
volontaires été reçu ce samedi pour se
voir présenter la structure et ses
missions quelque chose qui me tenait à
coeur et puis j'ai été élevé aussi dans
cette je dirais éducation où il ne
fallait pas jeter dans la mesure où on
peut donner et puis dit on essaye de
faire pour nos petits enfants nos
enfants et je pense que dans les
mentalités il ya des choses qui changent
également je suis intéressé par le par
le concept
de la ressourcerie le réemploi et c'est
vrai que l'aspect social en plus
m'intéresse donc voila c'était une
première comme bénévole à un intérêt
certain pour pour la notion de
réutilisation des biens et aussi
proposer éventuellement mes services
dans le cadre de la réparation de
certains biens et la remise en état si
un système de dépôt pourra être mis en
place d'ici trois à six mois la
logistique actuel de la ressourcerie ne
permet pour le moment pas d'apporter des
dons ouverture des portes au public le
23 octobre prochain